STEVE BAZYL: Yeah, so when you
pop open the API console, and
you're on--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEVE BAZYL: Hi, everyone.
And welcome to this week's
Google Developers Live for
Google Drive.
And today we are joined by our
special guest, Gus Class, from
the Google+ team.
GUS CLASS: Thanks for
having me here.
STEVE BAZYL: Today we're going
to talk about how to use the
Google+ Sign-In button
with Google Drive.
And Gus, for those who aren't
familiar with what you've been
doing on Google+, maybe you
could give a little bit of
background as to what the Plus
login button does and why
people should be using it.
GUS CLASS: Absolutely.
So we introduced to the Plus
login button, so the Sign-In
with Google+ button,
in February.
And what it allows you to do
is it allows you to very
easily authorize a JavaScript
client as well as a
server-side client.
And when you do this, you
get a lot of benefits.
The most notable ones
are over-the-air
installs for Android.
But you also get the capability
to do things with
Google+ and to get information
about your users.
So when you do this, you can do
things like get a list of
the people who your user has
made available to your app.
And when you do this, you have
information about those
connections between people.
And once you have those
connections between people,
you can allow them to engage
with each other within your
apps and services.
And this creates a better
experience for the user, and
it also can drive up engagement
on your site and
can allow you to have certain
things like viral growth.
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah, so I've seen
two applications so far
that use the Google+ login in
conjunction with Drive.
One of them we reviewed
a few weeks ago.
It's Magisto.
They have a really great
integration where you go to
the website, and you can
sign in with Plus.
During the login, it asks for
permission to Drive and does
the over-the-air install of the
mobile app, which Carrie
reviewed a few weeks ago.
And it was a really awesome
experience.
There's another one, which is
Carrie is going to review
later today, Jolicloud, which
also has some really
interesting integration with
Plus and Drive as well.
GUS CLASS: Yeah, Jolicloud, we
actually talked a little bit
about in our I/O presentation
where we showed off a couple
of the great things that
Jolicloud is doing when
they're using the
Google+ Sign-In.
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah, and we'll
see a little bit of that as
Carrie does the demos.
So one of the questions that
comes up with the integration
with Plus and Drive is how the
two sharing models relate.
And today, they are separate
models, but what are your
thoughts on when people should
do things like sharing via
Drive for certain types of
content versus doing things
like interactive posts and
sharing with a broader
community on Plus?
GUS CLASS: Yeah, absolutely.
So this is the notion
of private sharing
versus public sharing.
And the other things about
sharing, such as active
sharing versus passive sharing,
come into play.
So for Google+, we have two
types of sharing that are
relevant for developers.
And the first type is going
to be passive sharing.
And so these are things
that your app is
going to write to Google.
And Google has begun
to use these--
we refer to them as app
activities-- we use these app
activities to give better
relevance to the content that
your site is creating and the
type of content that users are
creating with your site.
And so that sharing model is
very independent of the kinds
of things that you would
do inside of Drive.
And then the other type of
sharing is active sharing.
So with active sharing, this
is done using the share
dialogue and interactive
posts.
So when you do these active
shares, you can do things like
you can pre-populate a form with
users from that user's
circles, and then those users
would receive notifications
across Google.
And when you do this, you create
really engaging shares.
And then that user can be
brought into your content
directly from the
Google+ stream.
So with Drive, there's the
shares that you perform on
Drive, and these are making
things available to users.
When you share actively on
Google+ using an interactive
post, Google+ has a proxy that
needs to be able to access
that content.
So within Google Drive, this
is restricted just to those
public shares.
I believe you said
something about
there's a tier for sharing.
So there's the things that you
create that are just for you,
and then there's the things that
you create that are at a
much more refined point.
STEVE BAZYL: Yeah, and I think
when we were talking about
this the other day, one of the
examples that we came up with
is something like maybe a
scrapbooking application where
I may want to keep my
raw materials--
my photos, my clip art--
in Drive, maybe invite some
family members to work on that
in a very limited context.
But then when I want to start
expanding out to my broader
family and friends, then doing
a public share or a limited
share on Google+, making it
interactive, you can have a
very engaging experience with
the finished content.
GUS CLASS: Yeah, so for in
that scrapbook example,
there's that, I'm creating
a raw materials
that are for my scrapbook.
And then, now I'm looking
for collaborators.
And so then using an interactive
post, you can draw
on those collaborators.
And then at the end of day,
you can use those files to
share directly from Google
Drive into Google+.
STEVE BAZYL: Right.
And you could always use the
Drive API to expand the ACLs
for a particular file to
match your sharing
via Google+ as well.
So are there any particular tips
or advice for using it?
I actually tried to do this
myself, and actually it was
really easy to use the
Google+ login.
I had actually modified our
quick-start for iOS.
And there are a few technical
issues that run into trying to
combine the two, but they're
pretty easy to work around.
And we'll share some of those
details on the community or
maybe a blog post.
But other than that, are there
specific best practices?
GUS CLASS: Yeah, there's a whole
lot of best practices,
and we're going to try to get
deep into those inside of a
GDL series that we're working
on right now.
But at a high level, the big
things that you can do right
now are going to be when you
use the sign in scope, take
advantage of that user's data.
So reflect the user's profile
back to them.
Show them their picture, and
let them know that their
friends are there and that
you're going to use their
social data to make a better
experience for them.
And connect users within your
site using those people that
the users made available
to you.
And most importantly, just
don't surprise the user.
Give them an experience so
that they know how you're
using their data, and make
sure that you follow the
requirements that we have for
Google+ Sign-In integrations.
STEVE BAZYL: That's
great information.
And actually, Carrie's going
to show us some of this in
practice with a demonstration
of Jolicloud in
our app of the week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: App of the Week.
CARRIE ROWE: Hi, everybody.
I am Carrie.
And I'm really excited to demo
Jolicloud for you guys today.
This is a great integration
between Google+ and Drive, so
let's see how it works.
So right here, you can see I
can sign in with Google+.
And what's really great, the
next window, it allows me to
add in any other products
that I want.
And so Jolicloud is an online
content management
system in the cloud.
So everybody has YouTube
videos they like, their
Google+ account, Facebook,
Drive, Picasa.
You have all these different
places on the internet where
you have content, and Jolicloud
allows you to access
everything in one place.
And better yet, it allows
you to give
permission all in one place.
So I want to add Google Drive
into my Jolicloud.
And then when I click Sign in
with Google, you'll see on the
next page it's prompting me
for permission to access
everything in Google Drive.
So I'm going to accept this.
GUS CLASS: Actually, I'll jump
in here and say that the
really interesting thing that
Jolicloud is doing here is
they're dynamically creating
that scopes, the scopes that
they are adding to the Sign-In
button, before they render it.
And when they do this, it
doesn't surprise the user,
because the user says, oh, I
said that I want to give
Jolicloud access to
my Google Drive.
And so when they do this, it
creates a great experience for
the user, and it also will draw
more users to actually
click all the way through and
sign up and sign in with
Google+, which is really the
ultimate goal that you have
when performing these sign
in integrations.
CARRIE ROWE: Yeah, thanks.
So it's a really, really great
example of how you can use
Google Drive and Google+
together.
And so you see now, now that
they've given permission, I've
signed in to Jolicloud.
Right here on my browser, I can
see that Google Drive and
Google+ are both
loaded already.
And, let's see, on my Google+
page, you can see I'm a huge
fan of animals, especially
baby animals.
And then all of my Drive stuff,
the folders are right
here, ready for me, waiting.
And I can use all
of my documents.
So this is a really
great integration.
Definitely check it out if you
have a lot of online content
like most people do.
And we love to see what
everybody's building, and
thanks for sharing the
extra insight.
So that's it for
our GDL today.
I wanted to thank the
Gus for coming on.
If you're interested in learning
more about Google+,
they do their GDLs
today as well.
They will be on-air today at
2:30 talking about what's new
with Hangouts.
So definitely check that out.
And next week we'll be back
with our Drive GDL to talk
about DocuSign.
They're one of our
largest partners.
We're really excited to host
them, so definitely come back
next week and check that out.
So thanks, guys, very
much, and we'll see
everybody next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]